nous sommes devant un tableau qui a été
peint par numa desjardins qui était un
artiste mauricien on n'a pas beaucoup de
renseignements sur lui notamment ne
connais pas ces dates de naissance et de
décès mais et numa desjardins a décidé
de de peindre ce tableau qui est
intitulé vue de saint denis en 1854
cette composition qui montrent en fait
l'île de la réunion et notamment la
ville de saint denis ville la rue de la
mer vue de l'océan indien est une
représentation assez classique du
paysage réunionnais puisque on a des
témoignages sous forme de dessin sous
forme de dito graphie
ou sous forme de gravure qui
reprennent exactement le même type de
composition c'est à dire
cette arrivée
devant saint denis par bateau et cette
vision globale qui permet de résumer en
fait l'île de la réunion et
effectivement si on se reporte au 19e
siècle et jusqu'à la développement de
l'aviation dans les relations entre
l'europe et la réunion du 20e siècle
comment arriver tournoi rhénan arrivés
par la mer donc ce point de vue ce
paysage cette découverte de l'île se
fait toujours de cette façon on arrive
progressivement et on voit apparaître on
voit surgir une grande montagne dans
l'eau en l'occurrence l'île de la
réunion et ce paysage
le num à desjardins la composent et en
en tenant compte des
référence en tenant compte des critères
en tenant compte de la de la tradition
de la peinture de paysage
établi durant depuis quasiment deux
siècles et il le composant faisant des
plans un premier plan deuxième plan un
troisième plan est ici ce qui est
intéressant c'est que il a joué sur des
formes géométriques c'était à coeuve le
premier plan on le voit c'est ce grand
rectangle qui est à l'avant du tableau
cette mer agitée cette mer sombre juste
éclairé par quelques petites touches de
blanc qui symbolise légumes est aussi
animé au premier plan avec deux petits
bateaux de petite barque qui finalement
sont là pour attirer notre regard et
nous dire regardez entrer dans le
tableau et participent ces deux bacs en
plus se dirige vers la côte tout comme
la crête des vagues qui forment des
sorts de ligne blanche c'est ensuite le
dessin on voit que sa forme quelque
chose de rayonnant qui convergent à peu
près vers un point qui se trouve là donc
ce premier plan qui forme à un grand
rectangle en fait constituer la base des
tableaux constitué de premier plan au
second plan le desjardins a résumé en
fait l'île dans une sorte de grand
triangle dont on aurait les deux grands
côté ici est un petit côté de ce côté ci
c'est la terre c'est les mêmes la
montagne c'est lille c'est la ville de
saint denis dont on aperçoit des
principaux monuments la cathédrale de
saint-denis l'hôpital militaire la
caserne d'infanterie de marine qui est
aujourd'hui la casa de lambert donc on
aperçoit la ville on devine la ville on
devine l'agitation du port de saint
denis avec tous les bateaux que l'on
aperçoit au second plan et on a utilisé
aussi quelque chose assez classique pour
faire la perspective de ce paysage on
fait quelque chose plus foncé au premier
plan vers quelque chose de plus clair au
dernier plan et enfin au dessus de ce
second plan en fait on a le troisième
plan qui est le ciel les nuages qui
occupe quand même presque
deux tiers du tableau qui est une sorte
de par le pipe aide et qui constitue la
dernière partie de tableau donc le
premier plan le deuxième plan le
troisième plan avec une utilisation de
la couleur du fond c'est du plus clair
et encore du plus clair qui permettent
d'introduire la perspective à
l'intérieur du tableau ce ses toiles est
intéressant dans la mesure où on connaît
trois tableaux de numa desjardins au
monde y en a deux à l'île maurice y en a
un à l'île de la réunion c'est un
peintre qui est très très peu connu mais
qui fait partie justement de ces
artistes qui ont travaillé dans l'océan
indien et qui ont laissé une production
artistique intéressant et qui permet de
se souvenir de se remémorer est en tout
cas de de découvrir comment on a pu
peindre les paysages à la réunion au 19e
siècle